just bring some live pictures coming as
in to us from Athens this is of a huge
fire on the east side of the Greek
capital a been told that 35 fighters are
tackling the blaze apparently had spread
very quickly because of high winds this
is the image horse mountain and it's
very near can't quite see the scale of
it there but you can almost see it
encroaching on two very densely
populated areas lots of pictures on
Twitter of this as well people taking
taking pictures on their balconies and
saying how close it is to their homes a
lot of concern there they're saying it's
on the hypnotist Ridge over Athens very
near densely populated area keep an eye
on those pictures and bringing more as
we get